the biggest mistakes that i see the  newest entrepreneurs doing is they're  solving a problem that doesn't exist and  they spend most their time doing this  because if they have a preference or  because they think it's interesting not  because it's what the business needs and  so our goal as entrepreneurs is to  simply identify what is the true  constraint of the business at this  moment and then redirect all of our  resources towards solving it so that we  can then de-bottleneck it and create the  next constraint and at the end of the  day all businesses is moving from one  constraint to the next and moving along  the pipeline until you go back to the  beating and create more demand